so chat GPT is a superpower for teaching
and learning we're probably sick of
headlines like this but I believe this
is so and I believe it's especially true
for teaching and learning with code
and so what I'd like to share with you
today is my experience of teaching with
chat GPT in my interaction design class
at the California College of Art
but before I talk about new ways of
teaching and learning with code we need
to take a look at the way it's been
taught historically
so this is something that might look
familiar to you it's a hello world
script that writes two words onto a
screen and it looks complicated and
impenetrable and this is the way most of
us
are exposed to coding and when I first
started learning how to code I had a
professor who wrote variables and
functions on the board with a Blackboard
I struggled my way to a d on the midterm
and I dropped out
so what would a new Hello World
experience in the world of AI look like
well it might be a little bit like this
this is a music visualization that I
developed using p5.js and it connected
to the accelerometer in an iPhone so
that as you moved the phone around the
shape would change and you could switch
between tracks
as you might expect this was a little
complicated coding-wise and I plopped my
students right into these hundreds of
lines of code and they were intimidated
but I told them I don't expect you to
learn every little piece of code and
every little variable instead we're
going to work together with chat GPT to
make this project your own and to do
that we're going to use natural language
that's what chat CPT really affords us
so I'll show you some of the things that
my students did once I gave them that
project chat GPD doesn't make the best
slides but one of the first things
students wanted to do was instead of a
still image in the background could I
have a moving video and this allowed me
to explain where the background was
rendered what an array is and how it
works
I had another student who didn't just
want one visualization in the center of
the screen he wanted two of them coming
together and apart like cell mitosis it
was complicated it'll make more sense if
I show you some examples of their work
so the first example I want to show you
is from Clarisse so you can see she has
videos playing in the background as she
moves the phone the track and the image
changes and she changed the particles
from circles to triangles which allowed
me to teach about classes and objects
my next student Abed he ditched the
whole notion of a circle and instead had
these waveforms growing together and
apart you'll see him as he moves his
phone he switches the track he made the
experience unique and his own and we
worked a lot with chat GPT to refine it
the last example I'll show you is from
wechen he wanted to have two
visualizations and of course swap out
the music and the image and was able to
make that work and as you see him moving
his phone you'll see the image and the
the waveforms kind of change he's
actually demonstrating right now the
volume goes down as you lower the phone
the volume comes up
they really liked this I got good
feedback my favorite feedback was the
coding parts are a bit too hard or some
of the class material is too difficult
because working with AI and machine
learning doesn't make things easier
teaching and learning is still hard
so fi what does this mean so what five
takeaways to inform teaching and
learning that I gathered from this class
the first concept I want to share the
first idea
is that Concepts
and problem solving are what really
matter Mastery doesn't nobody has to go
through memorizing syntax and doing that
hello world example anymore and instead
we can use computational thinking and
natural language to create with code
and this leads to the second takeaway I
want to share that exploration matters
more than Direction I could plot my
students in something really complex and
they could with chat GPT and my help
chart their own path not build piece by
piece in a directed way
but chat gbt isn't perfect
machine Learning Systems generate
examples not answers they still needed
my help to integrate the code that
chatgpt was giving them and I had to
walk around and work with them
individually to make it work doesn't
work out of the box which gets to the
fourth point this technology actually
means that more is required of teachers
and students not less
we've been empowered but with that
empowerment comes expectations we can do
more we have to teach more we have to
know more it's just different
and lastly artificial intelligence is
here we have a responsibility to teach
and learn with it chatgpt is in the news
now but many of you probably are already
aware of new models that are coming out
that are even more accessible and easy
to run
this is my class we were small which
made it a little bit easier to work with
this technology but I think these ideas
scale and will have long-term impact on
how we teach and learn going forward
so thank you very much and uh appreciate
it
foreign